Pasead durante cuatro meses con tres deseos,
y las ideas empezarán a surgir.
Creo que todo el mundo debería hacerlo-- pensad que tenéis tres deseos.
Y ¿qué haríais? Realmente es un buen ejercicio
el profundizar en las cosas que sentís que son importantes.
y reflexionar profundamente acerca del mundo que nos rodea.
Y pensar que, ¿puede realmente un individuo hacer algo,
o que se le ocurra algo,
que pueda conseguir arrastrar a otros ahí fuera y marcar una diferencia?
Inspirado por la naturaleza - ese es el tema aquí.
Y pienso, francamente, así es como yo empecé.
Me empezó a interesar mucho el paisaje, como canadiense.
Tenemos este Gran Norte. Y había una población bastante pequeña,
y mi padre era un apasionado del aire libre
Así que realmente tuve la oportunidad de experimentar eso.
Y nunca pude realmente entender qué era, o cómo eso me estaba informando.
Pero lo que yo creo que me estaba diciendo
es que somos esta cosa transitoria que está pasando .
Y que la naturaleza que vemos ahí fuera - las costas intactas,
los bosques intactos que tuve la oportunidad de ver --
realmente me traen una sensación de tiempo geológico,
que esto lleva mucho tiempo ahí
y que lo estamos experimentando de una manera distinta.
Y eso, para mí, fue un punto de referencia que pienso que necesitaba
para ser capaz de hacer el trabajo que hice.
Y salí fuera e hice esta imagen de hierba brotando en primavera,
al lado de un camino
Este renacimento de la hierba. Y entonces salí durante años
intentando fotografiar el paisaje prístino.
Pero como fotógrafo artístico, de algún modo sentía
que eso no iba a funcionar ahí fuera --
que habría problemas para hacer de esto una carrera como fotógrafo artístico.
Y estaba contínuamente siendo engullido por ese tipo de foto de calendario,
o algo de esa naturaleza, y que no podía salir de ahí.
Así que empecé a pensar, ¿cómo puedo pensar el paisaje de otro modo?
Decidí pensar el paisaje de otro modo
como el paisaje que hemos transformado.
Tuve una especie de epifanía cuando estaba perdido en Pennsylvania,
y giré a la izquierda para inentar volver a la autopista.
Y acabé en un pueblo llamado Frackville.
Salí del coche, me puse de pie,
y era un pueblo minero. Di una vuelta de 360 grados,
y aquello se convirtió en el paisaje más surrealista que haya visto.
Totalmente transformado por el hombre.
Y eso me llevó a salir y buscar minas como esa,
y salir a buscar las mayores incursiones industriales
en el paisaje, que pudiera encontrar.
Y eso se convirtió en la base de lo que estaba haciendo.
Y se convirtió tambien en el tema al que yo sentí que podía agarrarme.
sin tener que reinventarme.
Que ese tema era suficientemente grande como para convertirse en el tema de mi vida --
para convertirse en algo en lo que pudiera hundir mis dientes
y simplemente investigar y encontrar qué son estas industrias.
Y creo que una de las cosas que también quería decir en mi agradecimiento,
que creo que faltaba,
era agradecer a todas las corporaciones que me ayudaron a entrar
Porque hubo que negociar para casi cada una de estas fotografías --
para entrar en ese lugar para hacer esas fotografías.
Y si no fuera por esa gente que me dejó entrar
y por los jefes de esas corporaciones,
nunca hubiera podido hacer este proyecto.
Así que en ese sentido, para mí, no estoy en contra de las corporaciones.
Soy dueño de una corporación. Trabajo con ellas,
y siento que todos las necesitamos y que son importantes.
Pero también estoy a favor de la sostenibilidad.
Así que está esta cosa que tira de mí en dos direcciones.
Y no estoy haciendo un juicio sobre lo que está ocurriendo aquí,
pero es una progresión lenta.
Así que empecé a pensar, bueno, vivimos todas esas edades del hombre:
la edad de piedra, la edad del hierro y la edad del cobre.
Y esas edades del hombre todavía están vigentes hoy en día
Pero nos hemos desconectado totalmente de ellas.
Hay algo que nos estamos perdiendo aquí.
Y da miedo también. Porque cuando empezamos a observar
al apetito colectivo de nuestros estilos de vida
y lo que le estamos haciendo a ese paisaje --
para mí, ese es un momento muy serio de contemplar
Y a través de mis fotografías,
espero poder comprometer a mi público
para que se acerque y no sea rechazado inmediatamente por la imagen.
Que no diga, "Oh, Dios mío, ¿qué es esto?. Sino que la imagen le desafíe
Que diga, "Guau, esto es precioso" a un nivel
Pero a otro nivel diga, "esto da miedo y no debería estar disfrutando de ello"
Como un placer prohibido. Y es ese placer prohibido
lo que creo que resuena ahí,
y hace que la gente mire a estas cosas,
y hace que la gente se meta. Y eso, de alguna manera, define lo que siento también.
Es que me siento atraído por tener una buena vida.
Quiero una casa, quiero un coche.
Pero están las consecuencias.
Y ¿cómo empiezo a tener esa atracción, repulsión?
Incluso en mi propia conciencia, la tengo,
y aquí en mi trabajo, intento construir ese mismo interruptor.
Estas cosas que he fotografiado -- este montón de neumáticos de aquí
tenía 45 millones de neumáticos. Era el montón más grande.
Estaba a una hora y media de donde estaba yo, y se prendió fuego
hace unos cuatro años. Es cerca de Westley, California, cerca de Modesto.
Y decidí empezar a observar algo que, para mí, tenía --
si el trabajo anterior de mirar al paisaje
tenía un sentido de lamento hacia lo que le estamos haciendo a la naturaleza,
en el trabajo sobre reciclaje que podéis ver aquí
estaba empezando a apuntar a una dirección. Para mí, fue nuestra redención.
Que en el proyecto sobre reciclaje que estaba haciendo,
estaba buscando una práctica -- una actividad humana que fuera sostenible.
Que si continuamos devolviendo cosas, a través de de la existencia urbana e industrial,
al sistema --
si seguimos haciendo eso -- podemos continuar.
Por supuesto, escuchando la conferencia,
hay muchas, muchas cosas que están llegando. Bio-mimetismo,
y muchas otras que están funcionando --
la nanotecnología, que podría también evitar que tengamos
que ir a ese lugar y destrozarlo.
Y todos esperamos estas cosas.
Pero mientras tanto, estas cosas están aumentando.
Estas cosas continúan pasando.
Lo que estáis viendo aquí -- fui a Bangladesh
empecé a salir de Norteamérica.
Empecé a mirar nuestro mundo globalmente.
Y esto -- estas imágenes de Bangladesh --
salieron de un programa de radio que estaba escuchando.
Estaban hablando de Exxon Valdez,
y de que iba a haber un exceso de petroleros
debido a la industria de seguros.
y que muchos de esos petroleros iban a ser desmantelados
y que 2004 sería el momento cumbre.
Y pensé, "Dios, ¿cómo será eso?
Ver los barcos más grandes siendo desmontados a mano,
literalmente, en países del tercer mundo.
En un principio iba a ir a India
pero no me dejaron debido a una situación con Greenpeace.
y entonces me fue posible entrar en Bangladesh
Y vi por primera vez un tercer mundo, un panorama
que nunca pensé que fuera realmente posible.
130 millones de personas viviendo en una zona del tamaño de Wisconsin,
gente en todas partes, la polución era intensa,
y las condiciones de trabajo horribles
Aquí estáis viendo algunos campos de petróleo en California
algunos de los más grandes. Y de nuevo, empecé a pensar que --
era otra revelación --
que el mundo entero en el que yo vivía estaba siendo creado
como resultado de tener abundacia de petróleo
Y eso, para mí, era de nuevo algo que empecé a construir
y continué construyendo.
Así que ésta es una serie que espero tener lista
dentro de dos o tres años
bajo el título de "The Oil Party"
Porque creo que todo en lo que estamos envueltos --
nuestra ropa, nuestros coches, nuestras carreteras -- son un resultado directo de ello.
Voy a cambiar a unas fotos sobre China
y a través de China -- empecé a fotografiarla hace cuatro años,
y China verdaderamente es una cuestión de sostenibilidad en mi mente.
Sin mencionar también que China,
tiene un gran efecto sobre las industrias alrededor de las que crecí.
Porque yo provengo de una ciudad obrera
una ciudad GM, y mi padre trabajó en GM.
Por lo que esa clase de industria era muy familiar para mí.
Y eso también sirvió a mi trabajo. Pero ya sabéis,
ver China y la escala a la que se está desarrollando, es asombroso.
Lo que estáis viendo aquí es "La Presa de las Tres Gargantas"
es la presa más grande, un 50 por ciento, que ha hecho el hombre.
La mayoría de los ingenieros del mundo dejaron el proyecto
porque según decían, "Es demasiado grande"
De hecho, cuando fue llenada con agua hace año y medio
fue posible medir un bamboleo dentro de la tierra mientras estaba rotando
se tardó quince días en llenar.
Y se creó un pantano de 600 kilómetros de largo,
uno de los pantanos más grandes jamás creados.
Y también lo que fue uno de los mayores proyectos de los alrededores que
fue trasladar 13 ciudades enteras fuera del pantano,
y aplastar todos los edificios para que pudieran pasar los barcos.
Esto es un antes y un después. Así que esto era antes.
Y esto es como 10 semanas después, demolido a mano.
Creo que usaron dinamita para 11 de los edificios,
todo lo demás fue a mano. Eso fue 10 semanas después.
Y esto os da una idea.
Otra vez con --y era toda la gente que vivía en esas casas,
eran los que estaban realmente destruyendo
y trabajando, y siendo pagados por destruir sus ciudades.
Y estas son algunas de las imágenes de eso.
Hice tres viajes a la Presa de Las Tres Gargantas,
observando la transformación masiva del paisaje.
Parece como un paisaje bombardeado, pero no lo es.
Lo que es, es un paisaje intencionado.
Esto es una necesidad de poder, y son capaces de pasar por esta
transformación masiva, a esta escala, para obtener ese poder.
Y de nuevo, es realmente un alivio para lo que está ocurriendo en China
porque creo que ahora sobre la mesa,
quedan 27 centrales nucleares para ser construidas.
no se ha construido ni una en Norteamérica en los últimos 20 años
debido al movimiento NIMBY -- no en mi patio.
Pero en China dicen, "No, vamos a poner 27 en 10 años".
Y hornos de carbón van ahí
para la energía hidroeléctrica, literalmente cada semana.
Así que el propio carbón es uno de los problemas mayores.
Y una de las otras cosas que sucedieron en Las Tres Gargantas
un montón de tierra de cultivo que veis aquí a la izquierda se perdió
Parte de la tierra de cultivo más fértil se perdió en eso.
Y llegó un momento, en que dos millones de personas fueron reubicadas
dependiendo de qué estadísticas estabas mirando.
Y esto es lo que estaban construyendo.
Esta es Wushan, una de las mayores ciudades que fueron reubicadas.
Este es el cuartel general, o el ayuntamiento, de la ciudad.
Y de nuevo, la reconstrucción de la ciudad. Para mí fue triste ver
que no han asimilado mucho, supongo,
de lo que sabemos aquí, en términos de planificación urbanística.
No había parques, no había espacios verdes.
Una alta densidad viviendo a un lado de una colina.
Y aquí ellos tenían la oportunidad de reconstruir las ciudades de abajo a arriba
pero de alguna forma no conectamos con ellos.
Aquí hay un cartel que traducido dice, "Obedece la ley de control de natalidad.
Construye nuestra ciencia. Ideas civilizadas y avanzadas de matrimonio y nacimiento".
Aquí, si miráis a este cartel,
tiene todas las trampas de la cultura occidental.
veis los esmoquines, los ramos de novia.
Pero lo que realmente, para mí, da miedo de esta foto
y de este cartel es la refinería del fondo.
Así que es como casar todas las cosas que tenemos
y es una adaptación de nuestro modo de vida, punto y aparte.
Y de nuevo, cuando empiezas a ver esa clase de aceptación,
y empiezas a verles, llevando su estilo de vida rural
que deja una muy, muy pequeña huella y se mudan a un estilo de vida urbano
con una huella mayor, empieza a ser muy aleccionador.
Este es un disparo en una de las mayores plazas de Guangdong --
y esto es donde un montón de trabajadores inmigrantes llegan desde el campo.
Y hay unos 130 millones de inmigrantes
intentando llegar a los centros urbanos todo el tiempo.
Y entre los próximos 10 a 15 años, se esperan
otros 400 ó 500 millones de personas que migrarán
a los centros urbanos como Shanghai y a los centros industriales.
Los fabricantes son--
los locales son normalmente -- puedes reconocer una fábrica local por el hecho
de que todos usan uniformes del mismo color.
Esto es un uniforme rosa en esta fábrica. Es una fábrica de zapatos.
Y tienen residencias para los obreros.
Así los traen desde el campo y los colocan en residencias.
Esta es una de las mayores fábricas de zapatos, la fábrica de zapatos de Yuyuan
cerca de Shenzen.Tiene 90.000 empleados haciendo zapatos
Esto es un cambio de turno, uno de tres. A cada cambio --
hay otras dos fábricas de este tamaño en esta misma ciudad.
Esta tiene 45.000. Así que a la hora de comer
hay unos 12.000 empleados yendo a comer
Se sientan, tienen unos 20 minutos.
Y llega el siguiente turno. Es una mano de obra increíble
en ese edificio de ahí. Shanghai--
estoy observando la renovación urbana de Shanghai,
y ésta es una área entera que será aplastada
y convertida en rascacielos en los próximos cinco años.
Lo que también está pasando en Shanghai es --
China está cambiando porque esto no habría sucedido
hace cinco años, por ejemplo. Esto es la resistencia.
Les llaman dengzahoos -- son como chinchetas en el suelo.
No se moverán. No están negociando.
No les dan lo suficiente, así que no se mudarán.
Y así están resistiendo hasta que lleguen a un acuerdo.
Y actualmente están teniendo bastante éxito llegando a mejores acuerdos
porque muchos de ellos están recibiendo injusticias
A algunos les están echando en dos horas --
comunidades que han estado ahí literalmente cientos de años,
o quizás miles de años
se están rompiendo y desperdigando por las áreas suburbanas
fuera de Shanghai. Pero ésta es una serie entera de gente
resistiendo en esta reconstrucción de Shanghai.
Probablemente el mayor proyecto de renovación urbana, creo
que se ha intentado en el planeta.
Y luego, las cosas con las que las están remplazando --
y de nuevo, uno de mis deseos, y nunca logré ir allí,
era decirles de alguna forma que había mejores maneras de construir una casa.
Esa clase de colisiones de estilos y cosas eran demasiado,
y a éstas les llamaban las villas.
Y también, como ahora mismo, ya se están mudando
y los andamios están todavía puestos, y ésta es la zona de los e-residuos,
y si miráseis al primer plano de la foto grande
veríais que la industria -- su industria-- están todos reciclando.
Así que la industria está creciendo ya
alrededor de estas nuevas urbanizaciones.
Este es un puente con cinco niveles en Shanghai.
Shanghai es una ciudad muy intrigante -- se está explotando a un nivel
que no creo que ninguna otra ciudad haya experimentado.
De hecho, incluso Shenzhen, la zona industrial o económica --
una de las primeras -- hace 15 años tenía unos 100,000 habitantes
y hoy en día hospeda a entre 10 a 11 millones.
Eso os da una idea de la clase de migraciones y a la velocidad a la que va --
Estos son sólo los taxis construidos por Volkswagen.
Hay 9,000 aquí,
y se están haciendo para la mayoría de las ciudades grandes,
Bejing y Shanghai, Shenzhen.
Y esto ni siquiera es el mercado doméstico de coches, éste es el mercado de taxis.
Y lo que podemos ver aquí como una especie de desarrollo suburbano --
o algo parecido, pero todos son rascacielos
Hacen 20 ó 40 a la vez
y los construyen de la misma manera
como si fuera en la zona la vivienda de una sola familia.
Y la densidad es bastante increíble
Una de las cosas que quería resaltar de esta foto
es que cuando vi esta clase de edificios,
me asombré al ver
que no estaban usando un sistema central de aire acondicionado.
Cada ventana tenía su aparato.
Estoy seguro de que aquí hay gente que probablemente
sabe más que yo sobre eficiencia
pero no me puedo imaginar que teniendo cada apartamento su propio aire acondicionado
es una forma eficiente de enfriar un edificio de este tamaño.
Cuando empiezas a ver eso
y te empiezas a dar cuenta de que una ciudad del tamaño de Shanghai,
es literalmente un bosque de rascacielos.
Es asombroso, en términos de la velocidad a la que la ciudad se está transformando.
Y podéis ver en el primer plano de esta foto
es todavía una de las últimas zonas que se estaban manteniendo.
Ahora mismo, todo eso ha sido eliminado -- hace unos ocho meses,
y los rascacielos están ahora creciendo en ese punto central.
Literalmente, un rascacielos es construido cada noche en Shanghai.
Recientemente fui y empecé a observar
algunas de las mayores industrias de China.
Esto es Baosteel, justo fuera de Shanghai.
Esto es el suministro de carbón para la fábrica de acero -- 18 kilómetros cuadrados.
Es una operación increíblemente masiva, creo que 15, 000 obreros,
cinco cúpulas y la sexta se está haciendo aquí.
Están construyendo altos hornos muy grandes
para intentar hacer frente a la demanda de acero que hay en China.
Aquí estan tres de los altos hornos visibles en este disparo.
y de nuevo, mirando a estas imágenes, hay esta constante, como especie de neblina que véis.
Esto os va a mostrar en tiempo real, un ensamblador, es un corta circuitos
10 horas al día a esta velocidad.
Creo que uno de los temas
a los que nos enfrentamos con China,
es que ellos están usando un montón de la más moderna producción tecnológica.
En ésta había 400 personas que trabajaban en la planta.
Y le pregunté al director que señalara cinco de los trabajadores más rápidos
luego yo estuve mirando a cada uno durante 15 ó 20 minutos
y escogí a esta mujer.
Iba a la velocidad del rayo,
la forma en la que trabajaba era algo increíble.
Pero ese el el truco que tienen ahora mismo,
con el que están ganando, es que están usando
toda la última tecnología y máquinas de extrusión,
y trayendo todos los componentes dentro del juego,
pero el ensamblaje es donde realmente están incorporando --
los trabajadores están muy dispuestos a trabajar. Quieren trabajar.
Y hay una reserva masiva de obreros que quieren sus trabajos.
Esa condición va a estar ahí para los próximos 10 a 15 años
si se dan cuenta de lo que quieren, que es, ya sabéis,
de 400 a 500 millones de personas más llegando a las ciudades
En este caso particular -- ésta es la línea de ensamblamiento que vísteis,
y ésta es una foto de eso.
Tuve que usar una apertura muy pequeña para obtener la profundidad de campo.
Tuve que congelarles durante 10 segundos para conseguir esta foto.
Me costó cinco intentos en vano
porque no paraban. Hacerles parar era literalmente imposible.
Estaban como una estaca haciendo eso todo el día,
hasta que el director tuvo que decir, con una voz severa,
"Ok, todo el mundo quieto."
No estaba demasiado mal
pero les hacían producir estas cosas a una velocidad increíble.
Este es un taller textil fabricando seda sintética, un derivado del petróleo
Y lo que véis aquí es,
de nuevo, uno de los más modernos talleres
Hay 500 de estas máquinas, y cuestan aproximadamente 200,000 dólares cada una.
así que tienes unas 12 personas manejando esto,
y sólo lo inspeccionan -- sólo andan por las líneas.
Las máquinas están funcionando,
es absolutamente increíble ver la escala de las industrias.
Y empecé a meterme más y más en las fábricas.
eso es un díptico, hago un montón de emparejamientos
para intentar conseguir enseñar la escala de estos lugares.
Esta es la línea donde consiguen los hilos
y enrollan los hilos juntos
antes de llevarlos a la fábrica
Aquí hay algo que es más que un trabajo intensivo,
que es hacer zapatos
Esta planta tiene unos 1,500 trabajadores
La misma compañía tiene unos 10,000 empleados
y están haciendo zapatos nacionales.
No fue fácil entrar en compañías internacionales
porque tenía que conseguir permisos de compañías como Nike y Adidas,
y eso era difícil de conseguir.
No me dejaban entrar.
Pero en las locales era mucho más fácil.
eso os da la idea, de nuevo -- y eso es donde,
realmente, la gran migración por trabajo empezó a ocurrir en China
y haciendo zapatos. Nike fue uno de los primeros.
Y fue realmente --tuvo tan alto componente la mano de obra
que tenía sentido ir a ese mercado de trabajo.
Esto es un móvil de alta tecnología. El teléfono móvil Bird,
uno de los mayores fabricantes de móviles en China.
Creo que las compañías de móviles
están apareciendo, literalmente sobre una base semanal,
y tienen un crecimiento explosivo en los teléfonos móviles.
Esta es una fábrica textil donde hacen camisas.
Youngor, la fábrica de camisas y ropa más grande de China.
Y la siguiente foto es de los comedores.
Todo es muy eficiente
Mientras preparaba esta foto
la gente tardaba un pormedio de 8 a 10 minutos en comer.
Esta fue una de las mayores fábricas que yo había visto jamás.
Hacen cafeteras, el mayor fabricante de cafeteras
y de planchas.
Hacen unos 20 millones en el mundo.
Hay 21,000 empleados. Esta fábrica -- y tenían varias de ellas --
tiene medio kilómetro de largo.
Estas son recientes -- he vuelto hace un mes,
así que sois los primeros en ver,
estas nuevas fotos de fábricas que he sacado.
Tardé casi un año en conseguir acceso a estos sitios.
El otro aspecto de lo que está sucediendo en China
es que tienen una gran necesidad de materiales.
Un montón de materiales que se recogen aquí
se reciclan y se llevan a China en barcos.
Eso es metal hecho cubos.Estos son armaduras eléctricas
de donde sacan el cobre y el acero de gama alta
de motores eléctricos, y los reciclan.
Esto está ciertamente conectado a California y a Silicon Valley.
Esto es lo que les ocurre a la mayoría de los ordenadores.
el 50 por ciento de los ordenadores del mundo terminan en China para ser reciclados
Esto es lo que se llama e-residuo allí.
Este es un pequeño problema. La forma en la que reciclan las baldosas
en realidad es que usan baldosas de carbón,
y que son usadas en toda China, pero ellos calientan las baldosas,
y con unos alicates sacan todos los componentes.
Intentan sacar todos los metales valiosos de esos componentes.
Pero los olores tóxicos -- cuando llegas a una ciudad
que está haciendo esta clase de combustión de las baldosas,
lo puedes oler 5 ó 10 kilómetros antes de llegar.
Aquí hay otra operación. Son todas industrias artesanales,
o sea que no son sitios grandes. Se hace todo en los porches delanteros,
en los patios de atrás, incluso dentro de sus casas queman esas baldosas.
Si hay preocupación por la gente que pasa--
porque hacer esto está considerado ilegal en China,
pero no pueden parar de recibir el producto.
Este retrato -- no soy normalmente conocido por los retratos,
pero no pude resistirme a éste, donde ella ha pasado por Mao,
y ha pasado por "El gran salto adelante"
y la revolución cultural, y ahora ella está sentada en su porche
con todo este e-residuo a su lado. Es demasiado.
Esta carretera donde se ha llenado de teclados de ordenadores
está en una de las mayores ciudades donde se recicla.
Estas eran las fotos que quería enseñaros.
(Aplausos)
Quiero dedicar mis deseos a mis dos hijas
que se han sentado sobre mis hombros todo el tiempo mientras estaba pensando.
Una es Megan, y la otra a la derecha es Katja.
Para mí toda la noción --
las cosas que fotografío son de una gran preocupación
sobre la escala de nuestro progreso y lo que llamamos progreso.
Y tanto como hay grandes cosas al torcer la esquina --
y eso es palpable en esta habitación --
de todas las cosas que están a punto de salir
que pueden solucionar muchos problemas,
realmente espero que esas cosas se extiendan por todo el mundo.
Y que empiecen a tener un efecto positivo.
Y no es algo que no está afectando sólo a nuestro mundo,
sino que va a más -- porque creo que podemos empezar a corregir
nuestra huella y minimizarla -- aunque hay una huella creciente
que está ocurriendo en Asia, y está creciendo a un ratio muy rápido,
por lo que no creo que podamos igualarla. Así que la estrategía última
creo, que aquí es donde tenemos que estar muy preocupados sobre su evolución.
Porque también va a estar conectada a la nuestra.
Así que parte de mis pensamientos y mis deseos
es sentarme con ellos en la mente,
y pensar sobre,
"¿Cómo va a ser su vida cuando ellas quieran tener hijos,
o cuando ellas estén preparadas para casarse dentro de 20 años -- o los que sean
dentro de 15 años?"
Para mí eso es lo que hay detrás de la mayoría de mis pensamientos.
En mi trabajo, y también por esta increíble oportunidad de tener deseos.
Deseo uno: el cambio del mundo. Quiero usar mis imágenes
para persuadir a millones de personas a que se unan a la conversación global sobre sostenibilidad.
Y es a través de la comunicación de hoy
por lo que creo que no es una idea irreal.
Oh investigué -- quería poner lo que tenía en mente,
quería engancharlo en algo. No quería un deseo sólo para empezar desde ningún sitio.
en uno de ellos empiezo desde casi nada, pero en el otro,
quería averiguar lo que pasa y que está funcionando ahora mismo.
Y Worldchanging.com es un blog fantástico, y ese blog
tiene unas visitas cercanas a medio millón de personas al mes.
Y sólo empezó hace unos 14 meses.
La belleza de lo que está pasando allí
es que el tono de la conversación es el tono que me gusta.
Lo que hacen ahora es que ellos no --
creo que los movimientos mediambientales han fallado
en que han usado el bastón demasiado.
Han usado el tono apocalíptico demasiado.
No han vendido los aspectos positivos de
estar medioambientalmente preocupados e intentar movernos,
mientras que la conversación que se lleva a cabo en este blog
es sobre movimientos positivos.
Sobre cómo cambiar nuestro mundo de una forma mejor, rápidamente.
Y está mirando a la tecnología y a los nuevos dispositivos para ahorrar energía,
y está mirando a cómo repensar y cómo rehacer la estrategia
del movimiento hacia la sostenibilidad.
Para mí, una de las cosas que pensé
sería poner parte de mi trabajo al servicio de la promoción
del website Worldchanging.com.
Algunos sabréis, él es del TED -- Stephen Sagmeister y yo
estamos trabajando en algunas plantillas. Está todavía en etapas preliminares.
No son las finales. Pero estas imágenes,con Worldchanging.com,
se pueden colocar en cualquier tipo de medio.
Se pueden enviar por la Web,
se pueden usar como vallas publicitarias o marquesinas de autobuses, o cualquier cosa parecida.
Observamos esto tratando de construir.
Y lo que acabamos discutiendo
era que lo que ves en la mayoría de los medios es una imagen con un montón de texto,
y el texto lo llena todo.
Lo que era raro, según Stephen,
es que en menos del 5 por ciento de los anuncios lo principal es la imagen.
Así que en este caso,
porque es sobre un montón de estas imágenes y lo que ellas representan,
y la clase de preguntas que sacan a la luz
que pensamos dejar que las imágenes entraran en juego e hicieran que alguien dijera,
"Bien, ¿qué es lo que Worldchanging.com, con estas imágenes, tiene que hacer?"
Y ojalá inspire a la gente a ir a ese website.
Así que Worldchanging.com, y la construcción de ese blog, y es un blog
no lo veo como la clase de blog
donde vamos a seguirnos unos a otros hasta la muerte.
Este hablará alto y saldrá,
para empezar a alcanzar. Porque ahora mismo hay conversaciones
en India, en China y en Sudamérica--
hay entradas desde todo el mundo.
Creo que existe la posibilidad de tener un diálogo, una conversación
sobre sostenibilidad en Worldchanging.com.
Y cualquier cosa que uno pueda hacer para promocinarla sería fantástica.
El deseo dos es más de los de abajo a arriba, en tierra con el que estoy intentando trabajar.
Y este es: deseo lanzar una competición pionera
que motive a los niños a invertir en ideas, y a inventar ideas sobre sostenibilidad.
Una de las cosas que salieron --
Allison, que actualmente me nominó, dijo algo antes
en una reunión creativa. Ella dijo que el reciclaje en Canadá
entró fantásticamente en nuestra psique a través de los niños de entre cuarto y sexto grado.
Si lo piensas, sabes
que cuarto grado -- mi esposa y yo decimos que los siete es la edad de la razón,
así que ellos están en la edad de la razón. Son pre-adolescentes.
Así que es en esta gran ventana donde están en realidad --
y puedes influenciarles. ¿Sabéis qué pasa en la adolescencia?
Sabéis que lo sabemos de presentaciones anteriores.
Así que lo que creo es que intentamos motivar a esos niños
para que lleven las ideas a casa. Les hacemos comprender lo que es la sostenibilidad,
para que ellos tengan un interés personal en que ocurra.
Y una de las formas que pensé para hacerlo es usar mi premio,
tomaría 30,000 ó 40,000 dólares de lo ganado
y el resto será para dirigir este proyecto.
Usarlo como premios para llegar a sus manos.
La otra cosa que pensé que sería fantástica
era crear estos -- llamémosles premios objetivos
Y así uno sería para la mejor idea sostenible
para un proyecto en la escuela. El mejor para un proyecto doméstico.
O podría ser el mejor proyecto comunitario para la sostenibilidad.
También pensé que debería haber un bonito premio
para el mejor trabajo artístico "En mi mundo".Y lo que pasaría ---
sería una cosa escalable. Y si conseguimos que la gente ponga cosas
como un equipo o un laboratorio,
o dinero para hacer el premio lo bastante significativo--
y para abrirlo a todas las escuelas públicas,
o escuelas con niños de esa edad,
y hacerlo una competición abierta para que ellos
quieran esos premios y participen.
y el premio tiene que ser algo verificable, no sólo sobre ideas.
Las piezas artísticas son sobre las ideas y cómo presentarlas
y hacerlas, pero estas tienen que ser verificables.
De ese mmodo, lo que está sucediendo es que
estamos motivando a un determinado grupo de edad a empezar a pensar.
Y ellos van a empezar a empujar desde abajo hasta
dentro de las casas. Y los padres reaccionarán
e intentarán ayudarles en sus proyectos.
Creo que esto empieza a motivar toda la idea sobre sostenibilidad
de un modo positivo,
Y empieza a enseñarles. Ellos saben sobre reciclaje ahora
pero creo que no sacan la sostenibilidad de todas las cosas,
y sobre la huella energética, y cómo eso importa.
Y enseñarles, para mí, sería un fantástico deseo,
y sería algo en lo que realmente pondría mi esfuerzo.
De nuevo, en "Mi mundo", el concurso --
usaríamos el trabajo artístico de la competición para promocionarla.
Me gustan las palabras, " En mi mundo,"
porque le da la posesión del mundo a la persona que lo está haciendo.
Es mi mundo, no el de nadie más, y quiero ayudarlo.
Quiero hacer algo con él. Creo que tiene una gran oportunidad
para atraer a la imaginación -- y las grades ideas, creo que vienen de los niños --
y atraer su imaginación hacia el proyecto,
y hacer algo por las escuelas.
Creo que las escuelas podrían usar equipo extra y dinero extra --
será un incentivo para que lo hagan.
Y éstas son algnas ideas de donde
podríamos hacer promoción para "En mi mundo".
Y el deseo tres es una película Imax. Me dijeron que podría hacer una yo mismo
Y yo siempre he querido estar implicado en hacer algo.
y la escala de mi trabajo y la clase de ideas con las que estoy jugando --
la primera vez que vi una película Imax, pensé inmediatamente
"Hay una resonancia real entre lo que intento hacer,
y la escala de lo que intento hacer como fotógrafo".
Pienso que hay una posibilidad real de hacer una poderosa --
para llegar a nuevas audiencias si tuviera la oportunidad
así que estoy buscando a un profesor, porque justo ha sido mi cumpleaños.
He cumplido 50 y no tengo tiempo de volver al colegio ahora mismo --
Estoy demasiado ocupado. Así que necesito a alguien
que me pueda dar un curso rápido de cómo hacer algo así,
y me guie a través del laberinto de cómo se hace algo así.
Sería fantástico. Esos son mis tres deseos.
(Aplausos)